i'm here with the efficient and
magnanimous judge marilyn milian
and judge john schlesinger her wonderful
supportive and cool husband you're a
type a
marilyn and you're a self-proclaimed
type b
john and i've said that i have type b
execution with type a expectations
and we're going to get some time
management advice marilyn i know that
you have a whole system in style will
you please enlighten me
on how you're so efficient on time
calculate it in all the right ways and
get it done
you know um i i'm gonna take this one if
you do
let me just say her reminder timers have
reminder tips
okay yeah alarms have alarms i uh
i i forget stuff all the time drew so i
have taken
to setting alarms on my iphone
and when you set the alarms i i better
have written what the alarms for or i
will forget
why it's alarming um i do a lot of lists
i do different lists i use the reminder
list function and the iphone
and i keep them separate i have a list
for groceries when something occurs to
me
i have a list of books and movie
recommendations that people give me
restaurants i want to go to
a to-do list and then a to-do list for
my to do like i have a today list
right because the to-do list might have
stuff that is not
really important for today and the today
list i can't go to bed without taking
care of it so
and do you like check it off i do
there's like a little dot that you can
uh you press and then it can either
disappear
or it can stay there and give you
satisfaction with the dot next to it so
you can see
what you've done and i i actually do a
lot of speaking to women's groups and
we talk about being you know overwhelmed
and underwhelmed at the
same time and one of the the tips that i
give them
and that i do in my own life is when i
feel like the day got away from me i
stop
and take a a beat and i take a pat and a
pen
and i write down everything i got done
that day and and all of a sudden
i i'm a little kinder to myself in terms
of time like i just really i've always
it's funny because there's
uh i'm uh cuban by the phantom we're
notoriously known for being late all the
time i am the most popular cuban you
will ever meet in your life
because i don't like to be late you know
there's always tricks like moving your
clock ahead a lot of people do that but
i that didn't work for me because i knew
i got 10 minutes me too i i never wore a
watch and now i wear it but i only set
it like
one minute like late because otherwise i
i know and then i mess it up right right
right you know what i do sometimes too
and i thought this i got this actually
from my kids school is
they set meetings at 203 or 227
it feels so much more urgent for you to
be on time
than if they had said 2 30. everybody
somehow
is magically more on time when you do it
that way huh
well maybe we should start my morning at
like
407. i can give you a window on to uh my
time management
i would love it it's uh what i do is
usually i'm sitting in this easy chair
in her office just uh relaxing reading
something on my ipad and she comes over
and she says
uh did you take care of x or y and i
look at her and i look up and i say
yeah i got one of my best guys on that
don't worry about it don't worry about
it she'll turn to me and she'll go well
your best guy
better get up and get it done
yeah but you got to get a better guy
right
and i get up and i get it done we have a
different timetable on stuff
you know i'm so excited to have done
this show with you
and uh by the way marilyn your set
looks so good like i am so afraid of
the home show because i was setting up
this show
at home doing zooms and i was like i
don't want to do a show that looks like
this and
yet there's all you're seeing is a
couple of chairs on the wall it's like
again a clean up around here that's
where the camera hits you know pick up
their shoes
i had to do double takes onto your show
and be like
wait no this is an old episode because
it looked so good right right no they
did oh
they did such a good job there's a blow
up of the
of the set behind me and they pick
yeah it's just nuts
it's amazing then you see the finished
product and you understand just how
important
ev every cog in the wheel is that they
can make it look the way it looks
i totally agree and i think right now
when people really are stuck at home
i think our duty and job is to transport
people as much as possible and use every
tool in our box and
think forward and get innovative so
thank you for doing that
and it's just it's great for us to get a
window into your lives and see
an awesome happy marriage so thank you
john and marilyn for coming on the show
the people's court airs weekdays be sure
to check your local listings
you